I think it's important talk about these
things Jessica Biel is speaking out
clarifying her stance on vaccinations
for children after Robert F Kennedy
revealed he and Jessica teamed up to
speak out against a proposed California
bill that would limit medical exemptions
from vaccinations which got Jessica
labeled an anti-vaxxer there's so much
shame and guilt wrapped around you know
motherhood and and and birth and what it
means and how you do it and what your
choices are the actress shared this
lengthy pose to Instagram which in part
says quote I am NOT against vaccinations
I support children getting vaccinations
and I also support families having the
right to make educated medical decisions
for their children alongside their
physicians
she says her friends have a child with a
medical condition that warns an
exemption from vaccinations and if the
bill passes it would affect their
ability to care for their child
she then encouraged her followers to
read more on the issue Jessica and hubby
Justin Timberlake are parents to four
year old Silas I think we are also both
in awe of each other in moments and many
many moments I will do something and
feel that it's a bit of a mom fail and
kind of look over at him and you know
there's no judgment there so it's it's a
very it's a safe place I think that
we've we've created for ourselves and
for our partnership
[Music]